y la polarización que vive perú se
reflejó este sábado en las calles de
lima dos semanas después de las
elecciones peruanas seguidores del
candidato de izquierda pedro castillo y
de la ultra conservadora keiko fujimori
salieron a defender respectivamente su
apoyo a los candidatos con todas las
actas procesadas el maestro sindicalista
sumó el 50 a 125 por ciento de los
apoyos es decir 44 mil votos más que
fujimori quien sin pruebas hizo públicas
denuncias de fraude las que respaldan
sus simpatizantes e impugnó cientos de
actas que la autoridad electoral sigue
revisando la humanidad
y al mismo tiempo en la plaza 2 de mayo
del centro de la ciudad se manifestaron
los apoyos al maestro castillo en la
llamada marcha nacional o
lamentablemente la señora es una
corrupta que no debería estar no aceptó
la derrota que ganó aquí lo que ganó es
la demostración del gesto voto del
pueblo quizá del pueblo levantado todas
las regiones y protestando en contra de
la señora keiko que ni siquiera ha
llegado al 49 por ciento en protesta en
contra los señores y jurado nacional de
elecciones que hasta el momento no lo
proclama como presidente de la república
al maestro pedro castillo de ron es la
autoridad electoral y anunció el 16 de
junio que no proclamará el presidente
del país para el período 2021 2026 hasta
que haya analizado todas las
impugnaciones aunque de momento la
mayoría han sido desestimadas